just walked into the lab and i'm so excited to report and all this update look there's the there's a humidity the dehumidifier up top there with the filter gone and uh got the uh pump
nailer next to it they're starting to put in like the venting going down in there check that out i'm gonna get up there this ladder see what's going on up here wow looks
like people have been standing up here clearly a big pipe there that hooked that up there
Some lights hanging up here still.
These are cold water or chilled water.
Oh, so good to see it all up and going.
So hopefully that'll get done here pretty quick.
Look how big this transformer is.
This is the device that powers our atomizer.
Holy cow, it's massive.
We were going to try to put it like above there on this other side, but then it was too big.
So we had to put it here.
i wonder if we could put like get like a tall table or something to put over it well actually it meant to put out too too much heat i don't know find a way to make this area more useful but so awesome got
these cool slats going on here now electrical should be done yeah look at the vents get the lights up let's see here lights work how do you open this
box that's what's working yet nope not yet all right i guess they're still working on it
And then look at our cabinets.
It's beautiful.
Big sink put in.
That is so nice.
So they'll have to drill the holes, put in the finished plumbing there.
And it looks like we got another sink here.
This is probably going to be the, like, emergency irons.
I don't understand why those couldn't have just been in the same sink.
I thought that's what they were going to do, but whatever.
I guess that's how it is.
Got some nice cabinets.
Space.
We can put a whiteboard right here, probably.
Got our massive electrical, what are these things called?
Breaker boxes.
Look how big these breakers are.
They look straight out of like Marvel or something.
So exciting.